oh hello oh okay humne more of a behind
the camera kind of gal I get it hey
everyone how's it going my name is
Monique oh welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and life
thank you to grammerly for sponsoring
today's video and today we're gonna dive
into that kind of career in lifestyle
category where I'm gonna critique and
review some of my old resumes so today I
pulled four of my resume starting from
like early college until like pretty
dang recently and I marked all of them
with my critiques on what could be
better as if I was looking at someone
else's resume I actually haven't looked
up my old resumes in years and so it's
actually been interesting to look at
them and see what I had written in the
past and see which resumes had gotten me
specific jobs so you're probably gonna
watch this video for one of two reasons
one is that you're looking for some
inspiration motivation and some advice
on how to write your own resume or
number two maybe you're just curious oh
my old resumes have looked like and that
same curiosity is what leads some people
to watch reality TV but instead you are
here watching a video about my old
resumes because what our resumes is not
for one-pagers about someone's life
experiences and skills and being able to
see resumes throughout the year
maybe indicates some sort of like a
scrapbook if you will of someone's
career and before we move on to the next
resume I wanted to say thank you to
Graham early for sponsoring today's
video grammarly is a tool to enhance
your writing through spelling and
grammar checks as well as features to
improve your vocabulary tone and clarity
it's a super easy tool to use and
integrates right into your web browser
or your favorite writing applications
grammarly has been a staple of mine for
many many years if I had used grammar
early to write my resumes in the past I
know they would have looked much better
these days I get to write emails and
other important pieces too especially
check my tone and clarity gravity has a
free product but their premium product
offers way more and it's specially
useful in writing resumes there's better
grammar and punctuation checking to
establish a consider
stantly professional tone it also
suggests compelling vocabulary to avoid
using the same words over and over and
also helps improve the clarity of a
resume by cutting out unnecessary words
today they're offering 20% off of their
premium product when you go to grammar
early calm slash hello my you go make
sure to visit the link which is also in
the description box down below and level
up your writing today now let's get back
to the video all right so let's get
started on this so I've got my name at
the top contact and for right underneath
and then I've got my objective which
says to obtain a position in which I can
assist on computer science projects and
gain valuable experience in the industry
well young my yuko don't we all next
I've got the education section which
makes sense that it comes right after
objective because I don't really have
any industry experience at this point
and the thing that sticks out to me in
this section are three things the first
is that I call it computer science comma
BS when I think it's more commonly
written as BS computer science this way
it kind of looks like computer science
which is not really I don't know maybe
that's just my brain but that's how I
read it if I see BS afterwards the
second thing is that it says degree
expected March 2014 regularly people get
their degrees in the summer so June so
it makes me wonder like did I think I
was gonna graduate early I don't know
maybe I just like didn't know how long
college is gonna take or something and
the third thing that struck out to me is
just the spacing like there's a lot of
space between UC San Diego and the
computer science flying which is least
I'm gonna think that I just like added a
lot of random margins in here to make
sure that it like actually took up a
whole page and I think there's a way to
do it without it looking so awkward and
like this just looks awkward to me right
now
alright so next up is skills there's a
few things that pop out to me here so
first is that I put my skills in
Microsoft Word PowerPoint Excel
Photoshop at the top which like I don't
think those are really important skills
for computer science projects
I felt the most confident in them so I
put them at the top but if I were me now
I would put them at the very bottom cuz
I feel like it's pretty expected that
you know how to use those programs
nowadays and you don't really have to
highlight them even in most cases the
second thing is that I write proficient
speaking reading and writing skills in
both English and Japanese but really I
can just say proficient in both English
and Japanese
because resumes recruiters look at them
for seven seconds per resume and so the
less wordy the more straightforward
language I can use the better Nexus has
ability to work in an organized and
timely manner and my first instinct was
like I know you have the ability but
like are you good at it like you could
write something like excels in working
in organized and timely manner to kind
of give that subjective twist of like
okay but like are you good at it like do
you excel on those environments do have
unique skills that set you apart from
somebody else and then it's as strong
and diplomatic verbal and communication
skills I already know what that means
like does that mean I try to lead by
consensus or something I don't know I
just thought it was funny because I feel
like when I hear the word diplomatic I
most often associated to like government
and so I don't I don't know I just
thought it was an interesting word
choice to use there and the last thing
is that the use of periods versus no
periods at the end of these phrases very
inconsistent that's just like an easy
fix the next section is experience which
like I said I didn't have any technical
experience and so I put a lot of things
that kind of demonstrate my leadership
abilities and ability to work with
others so the first thing is a JSA + NS
you must city festival which like if a
recruiter looks like this they're not
gonna know what to say in NS you are so
I have a little note here to spell out
what those mean so I was an
advertisement company member for this
and I kind of just like right out here
are the various things that like we did
except I noticed that there were all
kind of like group activities like these
things like contacting media outlets
coordinating with other members
supporting the webmaster I had a
question or just like but what did like
you do how did you contribute
specifically because I would give me a
sense of like were you just
there or did you help actually take
action and do things while you were on
the committee like supporting webmaster
like what is but what did you actually
do did you like help reload the page
every once in a while did you actually
write content for the website or did you
actually design the layout so that it's
easier to understand and information is
readily accessible next I talk about my
roles in the Japanese Student
Association
I was publicity chair and gosh this part
is like wordy instead of saying like
responsible for designing flyers I
probably would have just written
designed flyers and instead of saying in
charge of distributing and advertising I
would say distributed and advertised
again because that wording is just way
more short and to the point a question
that I had to when I read designed
flyers and graphics for events I would
have asked like how many events did you
have how often did you do that and for
leading and organizing events for
members I'd be like like what kind of
events how many events how big were they
and then for the staff member part I put
like communicate with other officers and
staff members and planning events it's
like communicating could be anything as
saying like hello how are you and then
saying goodbye to actually like really
helping to plan and take action and take
action items and take notes and stuff so
I don't really like the word like
communicate with coz that's kind of like
a bare minimum to me I would like to see
more of like but what actually did like
what did you do
like assist Japanese exchange students
adopt history wife in America as a
recruiter I'd be like how exactly and as
someone who actually lived through the
experience I know that I used to help go
grocery shopping with them I used to be
a translator for them in case they
really needed someone to talk to to
translate between like some complex
English phrases and Japanese yeah I
think I would have just been way more
specific about what my contributions
were because writing about like what the
group did is great no but we all know
that like in group projects there's like
certain people who do all of the work
and then some people who do none of the
work and so I think is important to
differentiate like really the person
that did none of the work and still
takes the credit for it did you act
do the work and made a difference and
took initiative and learned some stuff
along the way but I didn't know that as
a freshman in college and that's okay
because why would I like this is
probably one of my very first resumes
that I ever wrote and lastly I works at
the campus bookstore as a customer
service representative for some reason I
just decided to like have a laundry list
of like these are the things that I did
specifically which is good good piece of
language but it should have been bullets
like if I was looking for a way to fill
the space this would have been a good
way but at the end of the day this is a
resume that got me the job that helped
me to get my foot in the door for my
first internship so it definitely served
its purpose it was fine at the time and
I'm grateful for it so I hope you
enjoyed this video and you got a little
bit of insight into what are good and
bad practices for resumes let me know
what you thought on the comments down
below and share any resume advice that
you have for others down there as well
make sure to thumbs up this video if you
liked it and again click Subscribe come
hang out with me often and be notified
about my videos and how I video show up
on your home feet if you like I would
really love that and so make sure to hit
smash punch those are really violent
words just tap the subscribe button
alright that's it for today hope you all
are well and safe and I will see you
next time bye